We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a voicemail with a question about the
future, which I think is not a question we
should really think about too much.
You'll know what I mean when you hear it.
Hi, David.
I know you probably won't listen to this,
but here I.
I'm just wondering what you think the chances
are of Trump being put behind bars after she.
Yeah.
If he loses this election.
I was curious on your thoughts that he will
face criminal charges for everything he does
in this country.
Brown just let me know.
Yeah.
I do not believe that Donald Trump is going
to spend any time behind bars, and I think
we should stop thinking about it.
You know, front from the beginning.
If something happens, OK, it is not common
that former American presidents go to prison.
I understand that Donald Trump is a new animal
and he has done things no president has done.
But when the Mueller investigation started,
I was reminding people this is not going to
remove Trump.
Then the soonest opportunity will be November
3rd, 2020, when impeachment started.
I said, this is correct, but it is not going
to remove Trump.
The quickest way to remove him is going to
be November 3rd, 2020.
And I don't believe that there is prison time
waiting for Donald Trump on the tail end of
this presidency.
And I don't believe that we should be waiting
for it.
We have one opportunity to remove Trump, and
the consequence he will face is losing reelection
and having his ego very, very triggered.
And that is voting on November 3rd of 2020.
So I understand the instinct.
I get it.
All I really do.
But let's focus on getting the vote out rather
than talking about.
Might Trump end up in prison tomorrow night,
Tuesday, July 14, the third ever David Pakman
show chess tournament.
The first tournament had 500 players.
The second tournament had seven hundred and
thirty eight, 732 players.
Let's try to beat it tomorrow.
You can register for free at David Pakman
dot com slash chest's.
Let me actually see, as of right now, we have
one hundred and sixty eight players registered.
All levels of chess skill, including no skill,
are very much welcome.
It's a community building event.
I hope you will join me.
I also have a really interesting chess related
announcement coming up sometime later.
This.
Week and tomorrow, Tuesday, we will have a
big one day membership special early in July
because of the virus.
About 300 members who signed up in 2019 had
to cancel their memberships.
They weren't able to renew because of financial
circumstances.
So we are trying to dig out of a 300 member
hole.
And in order to do that tomorrow, we're doing
a big one day membership drive to be notified.
Simply get on my newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
You'll see in the upper right of the Web site,
you can type in your email address and then
you will be notified of tomorrow's big membership
special on today's bonus show, which is, of
course, a membership perk.
We are going to talk about the truth, about
what's going on with the border wall.
I do want to address the situation going on
with the GooYa CEO and a lot of the really
dumb takes that we're hearing from some people
on the right.
And then just days after the owner of the
Washington Redskins said they would never
change their team name, they are expected
to change their team name.
It may even have been announced by the time
you hear this.
So all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show.
Get instant access at David Pakman dot com
slash membership.
And for the latest updates from the urban
garden, simply follow me on Instagram at David
Dot Pack.
I'll see you on the bonus show or otherwise
tomorrow.